the mellow dame dollar and others are
but you need the others to show up in
the first few plays of the game you have
to like his effort
mellow knocks down the jumper a little
turnaround
vintage carmelo carmelo anthony's one of
those guys joining
nurkic and collins returning such an
incredible run through the playoffs
taking the
blazers to the western conference finals
and davis comes up short on the run
gabriel holds it down wendy and gabriel
running the floor that'll get the rookie
involved
quickly
[Music]
checks lillard double team comes
bullet pass inside white side patient
two-handed jam on the beautiful set up
by carmelo anthony elaine
so right here if you notice mellow can
drive in but he stays
up under deep good job good finish by
white kuzma stayed on that side to give
lebron help
we call that zoning up the weak side
lyrics back on the floor give it to
carmelo anthony for three he's got it
carmelo anthony delivers
green with the foul here i was always
impressed with playing against mello
because you knew he had that bully ball
in the post but one of the things i
don't think we give great players credit
for
he typically wastes you get pinned
behind action but if he can find a lane
to the basket he's taken that every time
mello goes baseline after a couple of
pump fakes the active
down there offensively carmelo gets the
step on the baseline showing that ball
pump faking until mcgee bites on it
carmelo anthony guarding lebron james
ball poked away
great play by anthony with active hands
lillard knocks that one down damien
lillard
two for two to start anthony in good
position as he forces the ball to the
screen and then
just gets his hand in there again with
the exception of the score
three to two the blazers have bled
almost the entire time
anthony has to shoot oh and he knocks it
down as the shot clock expired and
falling out of bounds
[Music]
anthony wants to take caldwell pope
james coming to help
shoots over the double team back-to-back
jumpers for carmelo anthony
dame and the lake is choosing to switch
it you can overreact as a coach and say
well we're getting hurt with that that's
james for three lillard throws it ahead
anthony's gonna get another
and the game is tied once again carmelo
anthony
now he's got a taller guy on him and
kuzma
nice feet inside whiteside carmelo
anthony doing a little bit of everything
on the offensive end for portland
previous play
anthony with a beautiful left hand pass
coach nurkish too easily switching pick
and roll with caruso and anthony
davis that creates that open shot for
davis
carmelo anthony
his second made three he's got 11.
the lakers are eight for 12 from
three-point range nurkic
wide open defensive breakdown inside
it's going to just say good job of
building a wall but when you build a
wall you still have to retreat back out
to the three-point line
nurkic leaves it for carmelo anthony
assist number six for lebron james
howard's first basket
here is mello nifty move to the rim for
carmelo anthony
that's right provide a wonderful
distraction for those out there in the
struggle
so they can get back to work and
continue the great work they're doing
carmelo anthony
nurikich sends it out to carmelo anthony
and the three-pointer is in and a foul
you can roll it's the high pick and roll
and because nurkic is such a good
finisher inside he takes that one
dribble bounces it to the corner
and mellow hits himself in the head 50
from three-point range 13 out of 26.
kyle kuzma has hit his third three
there's carmelo anthony a little vintage
mellow right there skinny mellow
i'm picking him up full court anytime
i'm in the game i just want to wear him
down and do anything i can do
to help this team winning guys you
mentioned it you gotta love the fact
that gary is just embracing this
defensive task of guarding carmelo
anthony
getting it done early on back to the
basket quick pull-up
carmelo with another rebound
and he shakes anthony davis oh
vintage mellow right there oh school
mellow
the 20 shots a game the braves the hood
that's when he played in new york he's
trying to bring it back alive now though
[Music]
but then started warming up on the court
prior to game three his back acted up on
him he's had severe back spasms
the positive step is what they're
calling it now
went to the left hand and blew a tire on
his way up
mello now danny green on him between the
legs gets him up in the air and a foul
and count it
redemption for carmelo anthony oh my god
melo can't go back in his bag he can't
well i'm telling you as an nba veteran
just because the guy has oh but they're
gonna need all the buckets they can get
from
the supporting cast obviously we know
joker's gonna do his thing gordon
porter but when you can get it from
someone else to help out
32-30 end of the first quarter here's
anthony again
oh he got another one 12 points
five minutes you think he's happy to be
there oh
yes sir
oh yes i don't know i'm on this side of
the ball now
yeah it's a little bit safer at home and
then absolutely absolutely
a couple of turnovers back to back he's
got the most experience
in the playoffs of any denver nugget
121st
all-time playoff game carmelo he checked
that's good
lillard and mccollum and anthony and
simons
and nurkic on the floor oh nice pad
nice drop off wow rummaging in
down low carmelo anthony makes it
109 103 and a foul
but nurkic look at that in between two
defenders
and right now the blazers just looked
stunned team with all kinds of playoff
experience can they respond
anthony has to fire and hits
big shot for the blazers
this anthony three was actually
portland's first basket of the quarter
take that low percentage fall away from
beyond the arc it was the end of the
shot clock
had a huge opportunity now for damian
lillard it'll be mellow
trying to tie it up he's got it i told
you that's why they got the veteran
there
in the fourth quarter he throws over the
last 60 seconds
and it's all even at 91.
mccollum just two for nine on his threes
i don't wanna you take
it you don't have to ask this guy twice
mello to the hole gets it home
two-point game 11-13 for portland
that's a great job about carmelo not
settling we know he wants to take
mello over the smaller man
we wondered why they're looking to pass
morris the fourth year kid out of iowa
state
and just like that denver's lead back to
13.
tough shot by anthony credit denver for
being
in attack mode and that's a nice fine
anthony getting it down
nurkic before the news contest
defensively there and it did not come
and just kind of threw off his rhythm
anthony the fake fires and hits
and right now denver looking like
portland did in the first quarter
had a chance at an easy deuce well it's
got to be killing jamal murray to watch
this game on the sideline
anthony to hollis jefferson
well and more so on the defensive end of
the court you see the shooting
percentages
early portland at 54 denver at 52.
there's another layup
the nuggets on the back door all right
here's just no pressure on the ball you
want to help out
your defender on the back side that's
getting beat but j michael
let's say lack of defense they can get
in the shootout
i think you heard a little bit of that
urgency though with michael malone and
the nuggets
as carmelo anthony a little mid-range
jumper as cash
blazers all for three in this quarter
damien lillard
finds carmelo anthony gets to his left
hand pull up
that's good carmelo anthony vintage
covington running with
hollis jefferson and wisely gets it back
to his guards
here goes carmelo anthony he is hit it
counts
a chance at a three-point play he got
some numbers in mello and the patented
pull-up and then
carmelo anthony in he'll put it in
portland needing baskets quickly they
get a quick
two on the inbounds